Now's your chance to pay attention.
>> All right. U welcome back everyone.
We're back to talking about AI that
works. And our whole content here is
really based around trying to build
pipelines that have real practical
systems that you can deploy and take
into your agents that you're building
today. I'm Vivv. I make BAML and this is
Dexter.
>> Hi, I'm Dex. I'm the founder of Human
Layer. Uh excited BAML user. uh big fan
of Vibv and uh of everybody here and I'm
really excited to learn more. As someone
who works a lot in human in the loop um
systems, I think interruptability is a
way to take the next level of human in
the loop. Not just hey agent asks for
permission and human approves it but
creating good user experiences about
like oh no no no this is off track and
like being able to rest steer and change
an agent outside of the kind of like
predefined steps and workflows. If you
make a workflow so it can be cleanly and
safely cancelled anywhere and still
resumed then you are probably building a
product that is in the 99th percentile
in terms of like UX and safety and like
usefulness in terms of like using AI to
do bigger better things.
>> Exactly. So before we do too much um I
just want to start off with a quick demo
of the agent that we're going to work
with
and I think that's the best thing that
we can do at first. So, I have a small
little research agent that I put
together. I'm going to screen share my
whole screen. So, if you see something
you're not supposed to, please let us
know so we can clip it out of the
recording and we don't leak API keys.
Um, we're going to start off with a very
very simple agent. And what this agent
does is it's able to perform some
research on any sort of task that you
give it. So, let's just run this UV run.
Oops.
you
can't see my I'm sorry. I'm going to get
my second screen on really fast. I think
I should see everything that's going on.
>> I'm gonna see if I can figure out how to
change my layout here.
>> There we go. And then I'm going to pull
up the
>> Hey. So,
>> all right. So, what we're going to do is
we're gonna run u uh hello. py. And what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to ask
it to research something. The thing I'm
going to research is I'm going to say
why do why is wombat
poop square which it is if you didn't
know.
And what this agent is going to do is
it's going to kick off my planning task.
So it's going to go figure out what
stuff it's going to go plan.
And once this is done, I've now planned
eight searches. It's going to go figure
out what to go do. Then it's going to
run those eight searches using web
search from OpenAI.
And you're actually seeing that it's
actually going ahead and like running
the searches. It's giving me a little
progress bar and then eventually it's
going to go write the report. This is
kind of cool. But what's really freaking
annoying here is I don't actually get to
go interface with this at any point. I'm
almost stuck here waiting until it's
done. And what if I messed up? I
specifically want to know like what
about like the wombat's diet
specifically makes that happen in the
middle. Or for example, woodpeckers have
really long tongues that wrap around the
back of their head. Like why do they
have that?
Well, we should go figure that out. And
I want to be able to interrupt the agent
and not have to have it wait until it's
very much done until that happens before
we go in.
>> But you also don't want to start from
scratch. You want to kind of interrupt
it where you can maintain some of what
you've asked. But but not have to get
all the way to the end before you can
resteer it basically.
>> Exactly. Because it did do it and it's
like ah I really just wish it could have
just done all of it at any given point
and that would have been nice.
>> For the record I didn't know what Vibb
was going to demo today and I'm really
excited to uh dig into how this works
and how we make it better.
>> Um so firstly uh what does what do
people think?
>> Do people have ideas? Has anyone built
systems like that that is able to
actually be interrupted along the way
and then make it work?
Feel free to either type in chat, raise
your hand, or come off mute.
Dex, what about you? I mean, not to be
the guy who's literally on here every
week talking about cloud code, but this
is something I think the cla code does
pretty well where they have um various
levels of interruptability where you can
stop it right where it is and you can
just put in a new user message that is
corrective. Um timing that when it if
you stop it while it's awaiting a tool
call, it will take your directive
message as a denial of the tool call and
what to do differently. And then the
ability to cue a message is really
really interesting where it's like I
don't actually want to interrupt it, but
at some point when you get to a good
stopping point to the like agent
program, I'd like to insert this message
into the context window. And whether
that stopping point is like all the way
after the last assistant message or
there's some policy of like where cued
messages can be inserted uh that won't
like mess up a tool call in flow or
something like that. And so like there's
a lot of there's a lot of thought that
goes into building UXs around there both
in like what's expected from my side and
um what's actually like technically
feasible.
>> Yeah. Um what um while we're going about
this, what I'd love to say is uh Dex
send me over the whiteboard link. I'm
going to while we do that, I'm going to
go and show people how this agent
actually works so we can get an idea
around it. So firstly, I have some
debugging steps. So everything with
prints, you can just ignore of whatever
it is. Um, but this agent is basically
broken down into three specific steps.
Now, this is more of a workflow than an
agent. So, we'll swap it to an agent
really fast so we can see how to go do
that and then come back and do this as
well.
>> So, this agent has a couple different
workflows. One workflow is the plan
searches step. So, before it takes a
query and then it plans the searches.
The goal of planned searches is to go
ahead and figure out exactly what
searches I should make given the query
the user has. Then for every single
search the user has, what I want to do
is in parallel, I actually want to take
the entire web search that I've made and
then return in return for it, what I
want to do is I want to go ahead and
like for every single search, I want to
actually make the actual search itself.
And in this case, what the search method
does is it actually calls a summarize
search term method which calls the LLM
with a web search tool. So it performs a
search, gets a result, and then
summarizes it all in one go through the
LLM provider
and then assembles the summary for me.
>> Oh man, I have so many questions. But I
I know you're staying high level, so I
won't derail you.
>> Once I finish that, then I'm going to
take all the query and the search
results I have. So, the plan is now lost
and then assemble a report for myself.
I will pause really fast because it
sounds like Dex has some questions. Ask
ask away.
>> Uh, I'd be really interested to see the
prompt and how you're doing the like
tool outputs there and like what an
example like question would look like.
Did you write any like tests for the um
for the planning query?
>> Let's just do that really fast. So, what
is plan searches? Well, these are just
wrappers around simple functions I have
called plan web search. And what plan
web search does
is actually something really special
easy which is I just use gt40.
So a oops wrong thing
[Music]
word. I just use GT40 and I have a
really really simple system that says
why
why is a wood pecker's tongue so long?
It's a very common question actually.
It's actually very fascinating. Um, and
this is all I'm having it do. I'm simply
having it return to me. Uh,
we're given a query, come up with a set
of web searches between five and 20
based on what I'm trying to go do.
And it's a it's not it's not too
complicated at all. It's going to return
a searches field and return the reason
for the search and the actual query
behind it.
So, if I go run this really fast, you
can see what it would do for the
woodpecker.
It says function of a woodpecker's long
tongue, anatomy of a woodpecker's
tongue, evolution, and these all seem
pretty reasonable to be completely
honest.
>> And it's, you'll notice it's asking a
couple more questions that are more
broad. It's like unique features of a
woodpecker croissant. Because maybe I'm
wrong about it being long in the first
place. So, it's actually kind of good
that it came up with queries that aren't
about it necessarily being wrong along
the way.
>> Okay. But basically, you're doing a
little bit of um like in context
reasoning um and then asking it to
output and then do that five to 20
times.
>> Exactly. So, just tell me like five
things like the user wrote this query.
What are five to 20 other queries that
would make sense for the user to write?
Then I proceed to the next part which is
I summarize the web search. And you'll
notice here I'm actually using a
different client. I'm using a client
that is using the OpenI responses API.
But I'm doing something special here.
I'm requiring it have it's going to use
the tool call by providing this. And the
only tool I allow is web search preview.
>> So the model is required to use the tool
call along the way. So no matter what
happens the first one of the things it
will do is call web search preview. So
it kind of enforces this no matter what
that it will take the it will take the
query along with the reason
and then prop.
>> Oh okay. So you are actually using the
responses API which means the tool
calling happens on the server side not
on the client. We don't have to get the
JSON back from the model and do
something with it and then put that back
on the context window. You're just
saying one shot. Here's a string. Here's
your prompt. Go do as many searches as
you want and come back with the answer.
>> Well, it should technically only do one
search, but it might do multiple.
>> Yeah. Cool.
>> Right.
>> Cool. And then the last thing I do is I
write a research report. And I did not
uh write a test case for this one. Um,
and I I'll fill it out really fast just
so we can read the prompt more easily.
Well, whatever. Uh
um and you'll notice what I do is I want
it to give me like a short summary. I
want it then give me a final report in
markdown and then follow-up questions
that I might have. So, it's still a
little bit of structured summary, but
then I'm able to go ahead and go do
this.
And there's small things about the
prompt that I don't really like.
like I might actually prefer something
like this.
Um,
so it's a little bit more coherent for
the model.
Um,
oops.
I'm really bad at typing.
There you go.
So this might be slightly more coherent
for the model. So I might write change
it to this way. Um and now I'm able to
go get my query. Now even if I have this
workflow, there's a couple of things
that I want to deal with, which are what
I really want to do is
I really want this manager to be able to
be interrupted at any point along the
way. So there's a couple different ways
that I can go do that. But the very very
first thing that I have to do is I
actually have to run this thing in a
thread. If I'm not running this thing in
a thread, then I can't actually
interrupt it. And this is going
>> like a like a Python thread,
>> like a Python thread. And this is
because I'm building a terminal agent.
But before we go really deep into it,
the thing about
interruptible agents is you can't
actually build interruptible agents
without doing some kind of state sharing
across threads. So I'm going to outline
What's some of this?
>> You need state across threads. What else
do you need? You need you need like a
foreground and a background, right? You
need to like the primary thing that the
user is interacting with and then you
need stuff happening in the background
and how to like communicate between them
basically.
>> Exactly. So let's just assume we have a
very very simple thing. We have a front
end
and then we have a back end.
My front end is going to send a request
to my back end that's like start chat
and it's going to send some sort of like
message to the user that's that's like
what they want to start the chat with.
Then what I'm almost definitely going to
end up doing is I'm going to kick off in
my back end. I'm going to have some
agent loop
that is running
>> or pipeline
>> or pipeline. But let's just assume I
have an agent loop or pipeline. It's
just like a sequence of calls that are
being made. And remember, we all know
what an agent loop is. It's like while
true call lm
>> if done
>> if done return
along the way.
>> Else it's like else call tool basically.
>> Yeah.
>> Or call tool. Yeah. call tool
and then
>> update context. Yeah,
>> update state.
>> Yep, that looks right.
I hate this orange. Um,
>> I can fix that for you.
>> Thank you, Dexter. This is hurting my
eyes. Oh, that looks so much better.
Okay, so this is my agent loop. And what
I do is every single time the agent
loop, if I've done any sort of streaming
workflows, um, every single time the
agent loop runs, I'm streaming something
to the front end. Stream
after every call L1.
This is basically what a standard
chatbot looks like. Anyone that's built
an agent loop has done something like
this at some point. If you haven't,
there's some other videos that you can
watch in the past that show off how to
go build this. But roughly, this is what
we're doing. Now, the problem is
this thing, if I were to go send another
message, is actually going to start a
new chat. It won't actually interfere
with this chat. That is a problem. So,
you can't actually do it this way. So
what you end up having to do is when a
user sends a message while a message is
in progress. So you first have to have a
new thing called in progress.
So you need to be able to track whether
or not you're already in the progress of
another message. If you do,
you now have to you now instead of
submitting new messages to there,
you now save new messages on this side.
And this li this new message instead of
going directly to here actually makes
its way over to your back end again, but
it does a it does a separate call. This
one goes into
Q
message.
And this is where you'll notice that it
gets very very dicey in terms of how
things have to happen because it gets
very race conditiony very very fast. And
it this is where system design can help
a lot. What and we'll make this we can
we make can we make the original call
blue Dexter so we can track it very
easily all the things associated with
the original call.
>> What am I the color guy now?
>> Yes you are. Uh and we'll keep it red
for the
>> the hot key is the hot key is S if you
want to change the color.
>> Oh thank you.
>> SS to change to blue.
>> I have I have another thing. It's called
a voice command. It's actually very
powerful. You should try it.
Um,
but I'll try it next time. Okay. Oh,
that is really cool actually. The hot
key. Okay. So, the next thing that we
have is we're going to have a database.
And it doesn't matter if it's an
in-memory database or a long-term
database, but you're going to have a
database. And what you're going to have
over here is every time that this
message happens, one of the things that
you're going to have to make an
amendment for in this system is in the
very beginning before you go stream
this, you're going to send a message ID
to this system.
>> The message ID or is it like the
conversation ID?
>> We can call it combo ID. Um,
so this is going to
>> because right when I send another
message, it's going to basically put
that in a store that somewhere so that
when while the loop is running, we can
look it up later and see if there's
anything cued. Right.
>> Exactly. So we're as soon as this agent
loop starts, one of the first things
that we'll do is we'll send a convo ID
to the system. And I'm going to move
this um so it's a little bit more
obvious
>> in the order. Actually,
>> Claude code does this exact thing is the
first the first message emitted from the
back end to the front end is a JSON
object that gives you the session ID.
>> Exactly. That's what you have to do. So
now you've given a convo ID. Now
whenever you submit new messages, one
other thing you include in here is
you're going to include the convo ID.
And now this data payload makes its way
to the back end.
The other thing that you will do is you
are going to do another thing which is
at the very end of this service
you're going to send another thing
that's like a done event to indicate
that this sequence is done to know that
this message is terminated.
>> And this isn't a system where you're not
going to basically you're not going to
allow continuation of an existing chat
for now, right?
>> We'll come back to that. That doesn't
mean you can't do this. just to be very
clear still continue an existing chat
but I want to I want to have a slightly
different uh conversation around this.
>> Yeah because there's there's things
where like from the from the state of
the application it's like done but I
think a lot of tools uh from a user
perspective will call this like waiting
for input or like ready for next message
even though like hey the process is done
nothing is running but it's kind of up
to the user whether it's done or not
whether they want to like archive it or
they want to keep interacting with it.
Sorry, I should be very clear. Let's
You're actually right on this. Agent
loop done.
>> And that's the inner loop. So we talk
about I think we talked a lot in the
human
>> loop is done. It's not the entire
conversation. It's just that that loop
is complete for whatever reason. We've
hit this we've hit this return
agent loop
done sequence.
Like this is what we're here.
>> But what if we decided to exit out of
this loop? We talk about this a lot um
in the like 12 factor agents methodology
is like inner loop versus outer loop and
basically like inner loop is anything
where you just keep calling tools and
you go and go and go and process and do
the pipeline and then outer loop is
anything that requires a human to be in
in in in the loop as it were. So the
outer loop is like we hit a thing that
needs permission. Okay, now we're now
we're in the outer loop. We're going to
the human. And that's tends to be
especially with asynchronous stuff can
be much longer breaks between the inner
loop and the outer loop. But whether the
model is done and says, "Hey, I have my
final answer." Or the model is um like,
"Hey, I need your input." Or, "Hey, I
have a clarification question." That's
transitioning control from the inner
loop back to the human in the outer
loop. Does that make sense?
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> So now we're going to go do this and
we're going to stream this after every
single call LM, but we're going to do
one last thing. Now we're going to
insert some new text
and
on top of this
which is
>> this is the user's new message
>> ask DB for any messages
for this convo ID.
>> Can I can I rename this method?
>> Yeah.
Oh, sure. Yes. Um naming is not my
strength. I use LMS.
Um and then what we're going to do is
we're going to say state equals this and
this thing will take in the previous
state and modify the existing state
accordingly.
>> Oh okay. So now the logic for whether
the state is is at a point. You can have
different types of rules for when can a
message be injected. And so this method
can look at the current state look at
the ceued messages. And if there's
different types of cued messages, this
method is in charge of saying, "Okay,
cool. This message we can pull in. This
message we can't get for whatever
reason, but we're going to give you the
new state hydrated with any cued
messages that are eligible to be
injected at this time."
>> Exactly.
>> And then you got to do a little bit
more. We're not done yet. The last thing
we have to do is we have to emit a new
event.
>> We have to tell the user that we added
their message to the stream.
>> Exactly.
tell UI about message about update.
>> Yeah, because that that would change the
kind of display of it to be less like
this message is cued and more to like
this message is now sent and is being
like acknowledged and processed by the
agent.
Exactly. And now this and then the user
can now delete this uh stash that
they're holding and say now I've up I've
proceeded with this queue and moved it
up to the next step.
Um I'm going to pause here because we
did a lot of stuff right here.
>> Yeah, I almost feel like I don't know if
it is makes sense to take the time to
write it out. Um we should pause for
questions, but this might make more
sense as like a swim lane like sequence
diagram.
That's a good idea. Do people have
questions first?
>> And Char Charles had a lot of stuff in
the chat that might be worth checking
out. Let me read
>> for interruptibility. I use a user input
tool, but this is for chat UX my tool.
Yeah. So having the user be on to
interrupt is totally different because
just because you have the user interrupt
tool, that means the user can't actually
be interrupting it because the thread is
still running. What I need the tool
>> interrupt in the middle of a tool call
>> and and the tool would rely on the model
deciding to call that tool. Right? Is
that do I understand that right?
>> The to exactly and the model may never
call that tool.
Um my personal opinion is this is
something that you should build because
there's so many nuances to how you would
build this. And the reason that there
are so many nuances that I want to talk
about here are like for example this is
one implementation of this but actually
another implementation of this is I run
this and I actually run wild true
without this I'm going to I'm going to
I'm going to not modify this so I don't
>> yeah let's make another version
>> what I want
>> for the uh whiteboards later too because
then we have like different different
evolutions of it.
I want to I want to run this in this
way.
This is thread one.
This is thread two. And what I will run
is I'll run an interrupt mechanism where
anytime the database gets updated, I'll
actually crash this thread and take the
last known state and then restart from
that point onwards.
>> Okay. So your update state here is not
just appending to a context window.
You're actually like flushing to the
database at the end of every loop.
>> It could live in memory too. It doesn't
really matter.
>> Yeah. Right. When we say database, it's
like but you're like flushing it to some
shared data store, not just something
that's on the stack.
>> Well, in this case, just on the stack,
but if if I do the multi-threaded one,
then yes, exactly that.
>> Then like this basically needs to append
the thing and update the database. So
when this one calls it, it can go fetch
whatever the latest state was.
You can view it like this.
>> And is this going to have some kind of
like loop in it?
>> Well, what I'm going to The loop is
actually going to live at a higher level
and then we have some more questions
coming up soon.
>> Yeah, I wait. Um, gather
async.io.
And I I'll just write first because
that's really what I want
the red two. The red one.
>> What is it? This like promise.Race or
whatever.
>> Yeah, exactly. Race is the right word.
So, I'm basically going to run both
threads in parallel. And this is a
this is basically a while loop.
While
True.
>> Okay. So, this thread exits when the
agent gets final answer. This thread
exits when there's a new message. And
then you decide what to and then you
basically would like kill them both or
maybe
>> kill them both and then restart. Kill
them both because you're updating state
in either one of them and that's how you
go do it. So,
>> in here it's like if thread two finished
kill everything. If thread one finished
then push it back out to the UX or
whatever.
>> Exactly. If thread do finish, kill
everything and then continue.
>> If thread won't finish, return out of
the actual system.
>> Okay. So, would the input to this is
still like the user's initial message
basic or it's like it's a state. It's
still like a conversation ID or
something.
>> Yeah, it's still a conversation. You
still need a conversation ID. You still
have the state object. So, it's like
state state uh query. So, I can write
out I can flush out. Can you move your
mouse texture?
>> Oh yeah. Sorry. I'm like drawing on Zoom
when we have a perfect whiteboard.
>> Okay. So thread two, what you're really
going to do is this is going to take
thread two. This is going to and then
like some ID.
>> Yep.
>> This is going to take in like some the
ID into it.
And then
if
return update
and then this is going to run a return
update if you have something in there if
you have a cued message uh return
>> message
and then the second one thread one is
basically going to go ahead and also
take the ID but also the state as an
input.
And what this is going to do is it's
going to go ahead and go do this. And
then we're going to say like return
value equals this
if value from thread two for what I'm
I'm not I'm writing pure pseudo code. So
I hope that's okay.
>> Yep.
>> If value from thread 2 state.update
value.
>> Yeah. This is almost more like the go
select thing where you want to listen on
two channels and then take the first
whichever one responds first.
>> Exactly. Otherwise return result value.
So this is basically what I'm doing. I'm
listening on two separate threads and
whichever one returns first if the
thread two returns then I'm going to
update the state and then rekick it off.
If thread one returns then I'm going to
return with a value and that's all I'm
doing.
>> Sick.
>> Does that uh there's I see there's a
bunch
>> let's hit the chat. I mean the biggest
the biggest theme in the chat right now
is like should I use a framework or
should I own this flow myself? Uh
>> yeah I my theory is like you you just
saw two totally different
implementations here. One where I'm just
doing it in the Y loop one where I'm
doing it as a threading system. And they
have both have fundamentally different
approaches
>> and trade-offs, right? Like there's a
whole bunch of reasons to do one or the
other.
>> Yeah. Yeah, if I want to interrupt as
soon as possible, I'll pick the
threading approach cuz that's what this
will do. This will interrupt right now,
abort the message, restart from stat
scratch.
This one, on the other hand, is going to
get to a good point and prioritize the
L. I'm doing some work before I do any
amount of queuing. And there are reasons
to do both. In fact, cloud code lets you
do both. You can hit escape and
immediately submit a message, or you can
actually cue a message and it'll pick it
up when you want.
And I think that's Amari asked like is
it possible to calculate the urgency of
the message? And I think like
calculate's an interesting word, but I
think building into your UX at least two
levels of urgency, which is like
interrupt and send now or like send at
the next opportunity.
>> I mean, you can you can build that right
over here. You can like build another
you can build another flow over here
>> of what it should do.
>> Yeah, that's true. Yeah. And that's
that's the benefit of owning the flow
yourself. If you want to add something
like that to uh I mean a lot of
frameworks will save you time setting up
the initial scaffolding, but then if you
want to like reach into the bo the black
box and change something that's not
exposed on the interface of the of the
system you're using, things become
really difficult. And so I think a lot
of what we talk about is like yeah, this
is not like the world's easiest code to
write and there's a bunch of race
conditions and you have to figure out
locking and you got to test it really
well. But if you want to build
incredible experiences, I think you're
going to want that control.
>> Yeah. And remember, building is not as
hard anymore because we have AI agents
that help you write some of this code.
So it's it's actually not as hard as it
used to be. So I actually find the
flexibility to always be worth it,
especially because I can just vibe code
most of this. I'm certain if you send
this diagram out to an LLM, it could
write this for you. In fact, we're going
to try that real fast.
>> Um, and you'll see what I mean. Uh and
the the beautiful part about this
approach is it's not actually either or.
You can actually for example this is
running on a while loop. You can just
like sleep.io
like every 1 second. Check this out.
And so you're pulling every 1 second for
interrupts. But over here you can also
interrupt at the same time. So you can
actually run both things in parallel.
It's like hey if I get to a good state
just do it right then. But if this thing
has been running for like five minutes
or like like we might even want to make
this 10 seconds. If the agent has been
running for 10 seconds, screw it. Just
interrupt right now. It's too long of a
wait time.
>> And then you can actually even have like
a custom ticker here which like resets
the sleep every time the agent does a
new thing or something like that or
every time there's a new user message.
>> Exactly. Like basically you can figure
out when you reset this based on what
other interactions happen. So, you end
up building like some really funky
relationship between how these two kind
of interplay with each other. Um, how do
I get an arrow head on both sides?
>> Are you trying to get the non the Yeah.
Okay.
>> I don't know how to put an arrow on both
sides. I should really
>> We're gonna we're gonna do a meta
episode where we teach Vibbob all of the
uh all of the tricks in uh in Excal.
>> I agree.
Um I think that'd be very useful for me
personally. I think I'll become a better
engineer.
Um, so that becomes something that now
becomes possible because we can build a
relationship between the sleep IO here
as well where this changes based on a
two-way system rather than a one-way
system.
Um, cool. I'm going to pause here. Let's
take on some more questions because I
know that this is architecturally
complex. You'll notice that writing the
code is not that hard, which is why I'm
waiting a little bit. It I want to make
sure we address any questions people
have.
>> Okay, we got a lot.
Yeah, controlling the user experience.
Um, when agent loops can ask users for
optional explanatory queries.
Uh, cool. I don't think there's any
major questions. I guess we can go into
just coding this up and seeing what this
looks like. So, the first thing I'm
going to do is
uh I'm just going to take this as a
screenshot.
And then I'm going to go to chatgbt.com
and I'm going to start a new chat.
And I'm going to say make this a mermaid
diagram that explains how to
build um interruptable
agents.
And it should be able to make the
mermaid diagram um automatically for me
hopefully.
um while this is happening and the
reason by the way I'm making a mermaid
diagram is because what I really want to
do here is I want to give cursor this
code and then I want to tell it my goal
and then when I give it the goal I want
to give it very simple context about
exactly what I'm expecting so that the
CLI tool can update itself automatically
and this is what I mean of why I think a
um why I think a framework isn't
necessarily useful because as long as I
can describe this problem really well to
the model, I think it can just do it.
And this isn't even exactly the exact
sequence that we have.
Um because in this case, this is an
agent loop. We don't have an agent loop.
We have a workflow. So, it's not even a
onetoone. But what I Mermaid
live this website is probably killer
traffic if I were them right now.
Um,
>> yeah, it's crazy the
there's some models that like or like uh
inference like chat providers that
render the mermaid diagrams in line and
I'm always just like so surprised that
like Gemini and chat GPT haven't adopted
that yet because it's such a nice way
for like an AI to communicate what it's
thinking to you.
>> I 100% agree. Uh, and now I have to
maybe can fix it. It's going to make me
sign it. I knew it.
Uh, we're going to go to anthropic
and do the same thing because I don't
have patience for trying to figure out
why the mermaid is not working.
Uh, Slack,
sorry about the delay here. Open demos
link.
Um, and then I don't want to copy my
prompt.
Cool. Um, and while this is running, um,
I want to talk about like a couple more
things. One is even though this seems
really hard, I want to explain why I
think this is really, really important
for almost every single person to think
about when they build agents. And really
the big reason is that my opinion about
how agents generally work is that what
makes the best agents today successful
is that almost every single one of them
has reinvented UX in some way. Cursor
reinvented the UX of how I use uh agents
or like just LLMs in general when I
write code. Cloud code did it again when
it went ahead and made it through the
terminal. And I think the reason cloud
code picked up so much popularity even
though cursor already exists and cloud
code had no free option. You just have
to pay from day one is because they
really reinvented the UX of how queuing
and waiting for stuff along the way
feels. The fact that I can just press
enter and not have to think hard about
it is a huge huge win for me.
>> Yeah. And the cursor one is like they
give you really in the human in the loop
steps where you're approving stuff. It's
like a really rich UX. like showing the
exact diff in the exact files with the
syntax highlighting was an incredible
step up in terms of like giving that was
one of the things we struggle a lot with
at at human layers like hey if you want
to put a human approval in Slack like a
lot of things require a lot of rich UI
for a human to like yeah if you're
reviewing an email that's going to go
out like yeah you can just read it in
Slack but if you're like labeling an
image or reviewing let's say a loan
application or something like this like
you need a lot more rich context text
and so yeah being able to customize the
UI and being able to customize the
experience by owning the flow of
information through the system becomes
really really powerful if you can do if
you can if you that's like where all the
good innovation is happening in AI right
not all of it but that's where some
really good innovation is happening in
AI right now so I'm going to do
something now which is I'm just going to
talk to cloud I'm going to talk to
cursor agent and I'm just going to tell
it that I'm going to use GT5 max I'm
gonna paste this in given that
architecture Um
let's try this.
Given that architecture, I want to
figure out how the terminal is going to
interface with let's say a similar kind
of agent where the main function can
actually query and cue requests coming
in from the CLI. But the research
manager can still run in the background
and be able to be interrupted with any
new messages that come at any specific
phase in its thing. I don't need the
individual phases to be interrupted, but
in between the actual phases, I want
them to be interrupted.
Cool. Um,
don't implement. Just tell me what I
should do in theory.
Cool. And I'm just going to give it that
along the way.
And
>> I had given you a prompt on Saturday
that was optimized for building plans
for implementing things
>> you did. Uh but I can't do it within
cursor. What voice agent am I using? Um
I'm using whisper flow, but super
whisper is another great one. Uh but
really I find that this is much better
because I can just like put in way more
information than I normally would have
otherwise.
Uh first it's making a web service. So
this is exactly why I did not have it do
implementation of any kind because I
knew it was going to do a web service
given this. I don't want a web service.
I want to mimic
the architecture
with just threads and in memory stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah. keeping it all in one
process and using like in intra
intraprocess communication the other IPC
>> just so it knows what I'm going for and
there's other ways that I could go about
this for example um I could say over
here okay now give me another diagram
or how to do something similar with a
CLI tool but no web server
So stood in is the front end
and some thread is the back end. And
what I could do here is instead of
actually having the model think about it
in this way, I could simply
and this will probably be fine. Uh
>> yeah, you basically just want like a
thread safe inmemory object, right?
>> I don't even know what this is doing.
uh in memory version, no web service.
Great. Yeah, it's going to go ahead and
go figure something out. It looks
somewhat reasonable. A lightweight
schedule thread if you want to cap
concurrent agent threads.
Um, cool. This looks somewhat
reasonable. And
this looks a lot more complicated, but
this also looks somewhat reasonable.
Let's just kick it off.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And so in the mermaid, you're kind
of optimizing. We talk a lot about like
when AI is going to do something you
want to put human attention on the
highest leverage thing and it's
basically like understanding the like
architecture of the system and then
understanding the implementation plan
and like if the architecture is wrong
everything else is going to be wrong. If
the implementation plan is wrong,
everything you write is going to be
wrong. And so it's like mermaid is a
really powerful way to make that task of
reviewing the because if the arch if the
model just outputs 300 lines of markdown
for the architecture like that becomes
really hard to read and this is a much
better way to kind of uh analyze what
the model is thinking.
>> Yeah, exactly. And I do spend a lot of
time actually looking at these visuals
because I find it to be really fast for
me to actually understand what's
happening.
Um, but I think this should mostly be
done pretty soon and then it should, I
think, work without really requiring any
new tools or anything along the way.
>> Oh, is it actually going to do it now?
>> It should. Yeah,
it it will implement it uh along the
way.
While this is implementing, do people
have ideas for other implications for
how you might other architectures or
something else along here? Dexter, have
you thought about that along the way
while this is running in the background?
This is the only problem with live
coding, which is we do have to wait when
we go back to this diagram. Have you
thought about other implications of how
you might want to go do this? So, we
talked about how you might want the
sleep, for example, to be uh re-rotated
based on how the agent loop is actually
triggering. What are other UX things
that you think would make a huge impact
on how the user perceives this?
>> Um, I mean, I think the idea of
understanding when and how a message is
eligible to be injected into the context
window, like building your own logic of
like these types of messages should be
dropped in right away or like, hey, this
type of message should wait until the
entire research is done. Like basically
being able to cue
cue for different like urgencies, I
guess as they said. like claude code has
the like inject it whenever or inject it
immediately. But I almost also want like
a like inject it like at the latest
possible moment. Like basically just
treat this as the next user message
rather than trying to put it in the
thread. Like I want the model to finish
what it's doing because I think it's on
the right track and I want to see what
it does. And so sometimes queuing will
actually say like okay we're done
calling the tools. Let's take the last
user message before we output the last
assistant message. And so yeah, the
taring and the urgency and I think I
don't know if there's a good way to
detect that. Um unless the user is very
clear about like if it says keep going
but when you're done then I would
classify that as you know okay this is
going to be the next user message after
the model is completely emits it's like
stop token done calling tools here's my
final answer versus like
>> as you're working do xyz or like stop
immediately and change it this way. Um I
think stop immediately always just needs
like user controllable but
>> I kind of saw this in warp as well which
is I'm I was doing this thing to reduce
the size of the BAML repo uh by hope by
like a third and bring it down from like
280 g megabytes to like 170. But if this
works you'll notice that warp does this
uh warp right over here says like oh the
topic has changed. Do you want to make a
new conversation?
>> Oh, nice.
>> So, it's actually really interesting how
you might want to go design that exactly
along the lines of what you were saying,
which is just because a message came in
doesn't mean that you actually should be
interrupting it right away. Um, is it
done? Oh, wow. That was very fast. This
is why I love
>> um and it didn't have to like
>> really do much. conversation runtime.
>> We'll just try and run it
>> and just see what happens and I think we
can talk about if it actually did the
right thing or not.
Maybe run hello and I'll go ahead and
continue. Uh why is a woodpecker's
tongue long?
And you'll notice I actually still have
terminal available. I'm still planning
the search along the way.
I can say
>> so you can say like make sure you
checkno or something.
>> Plan natio is a great resource for this.
And if it does it correctly,
>> I don't think I don't think it uh I
think it's continuing to running through
your plan. I don't think it interrupted.
>> Oh, okay. So, you actually gave it this
actually designed it to basically have
this is how the user signals it
>> is like what types of things. Okay,
that's interesting.
>> Exactly. So,
>> was this already in here or did this did
cursor write this?
>> It cursor wrote all this.
>> Nice.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So you almost can have like slash
commands or some sort of like way for
the user to specify exactly like hey
interrupt and do this
>> exactly replan query. Nachio is a great
resource for this. It went in and now
it's writing the report. Now the problem
is this went in too late. What it should
have done is re-triggered the
cancellation and then gone back up if
that happened.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And what I suspect will happen if
it does this correctly.
Um if it did this correctly I can go
tell it this. But you can see exactly
what it's doing now is it's doing
system. Q. Now I can go look at what
system.q does runtime.q message.
Runtime.q message. It just puts in the
event Q. And then what it actually does
is I see what this code does. Sorry. Q
message. Let's go find this.
In the actual loop that it's running,
the agent loop,
where' it go? I can't navigate this code
very fast. In the actual agent loop that
it's running,
you'll notice uh that where did it go?
This system.
This is actually checking if the runtime
is going to be completely done or not.
And I suspect what's happening
>> just looking at the like status. So the
runtime itself implements kind of like a
state machine.
>> Exactly.
Exactly. And that's what it does under
the hood. So I can go modify this and
figure out exactly what it's doing to go
modify this and make it work. But this
is the
>> Go ahead.
>> I was going to say like yeah, this is
this is a lot of code. We weren't going
to make you all sit and watch us do
this, but this is kind of like the the
flow you could go through to try to
implement this. And like these
principles if you can get them written
down well you can turn them into like
kind of core architecture for how you do
all this stuff.
>> Yeah. And you'll notice a couple more
things uh where I actually the what the
code actually did under the hood is in
the actual runtime it's actually
checking on every single boundary
whether or not there is a new cued
message.
So, if I actually go look into my
um uh why is a woodpecker's
tongue so long? And then I'm going to
prep this uh use
net go for
searching y
info.
And now I'm going to go cue that
message.
Then what should happen is you see what
it did info merge merge additional
instructions to the context right over
here.
And it's actually go able to go ahead
and like probably search nature for
this. But it definitely did merge this
in. And we can go look at the code, see
where this happened. Well, it's also
your your model doesn't have any
visibility into actually what's being
searched, right? Because it's happening
in the responses API.
>> Yeah. But I could print it out if I
wanted. But the current query right over
here,
>> yeah,
>> is going through and the current query
is being modified right along the way.
>> Oh, cool. You're just pushing it into
additional instructions.
>> Yeah, I just said additional
instructions. Nothing too fancy. That's
well I I cursor just said additional
instructions.
So this allows me to basically go ahead
and just have the merge along the way
happen without having to go do it. And
what plan
>> So every time you push the base query
into any of your prompts, it's going to
have the the core context there.
>> Exactly. And then what replan is doing
is replan is just replacing my query
with the new query.
And that's a bad name, I guess, for
this. And I should have looked at the
code a little bit more clearly, but
let's see if it actually found this.
It did not actually use a search. I can
go figure out where this query is
happening or not. Uh, and see where this
is being passed in along the way.
It's definitely calling write report
over here with the current query. So, it
should be technically passing that in,
but I can go double check and see where
that happens.
>> Yeah. Um, how about a live voice to work
like with the LM? Like the input is
stream transcripts. The LM's job is to
keep a set of notes updated. Question
from John.
>> Yeah, I saw the thing about John. Um, I
have opinions on how the voice agents
should be built and I think they should
be basically built in a super linear
way. Uh, where every single voice agent
that you build should operate really
really fast whenever possible.
And that is the only way to build a good
voice agent in my opinion.
The problem with this is, as you
probably note, is if you build it really
really fast, it will go off topic. The
user will change topic. You won't be
able to do correction. So, while you're
running on this timeline, at a slightly
separate timeline, what you need to be
building is another system that is
reviewing everything that happened
before it at a slower cadence,
>> like using a smarter model. basically
like
>> this it's hard to build high performance
voice agents because you need really
fast response times
>> but then you're having a smarter model
go through and maybe inject a message
like oh actually I'm doing it wrong we
should do this instead.
>> Exactly. And like the way to think about
this is this doesn't even have to be
like you could use an even smart model
on top of your smart model and go do
that. And what this a agent is doing is
this call is responsible for checking
everything up until this point this
point backwards. This call is
responsible for checking everything this
point backwards. And they all just go
back by one
because they can't actually check the
current message. So they always check
the state historically along the way.
And then what you do is if this agent
detects that something has has gone
wrong, it's a drift or something else,
then this agent
sends an interrupt message to this one
saying, "Hey, you are off track." So
even though the me agent is responding
over here in your software, you haven't
interrupted just like we had over here.
Let me see. Problem with the research
thing is actually kind of long. Just
like we had over here where we actually
like dumped out another thing, merge
additional additional instructions into
context and we printed that out to the
console. We're going to print out to
your voice agent something that says,
"Hi, I'm sorry.
It seems like I'm off track."
Right? You're just going to force your
agent to say that and then have it redo
inference from a little bit rewound up.
>> Exactly. So you're going to back play.
You're going to redo replay inference.
Exactly what Dextra says with a little
bit more context that's added in from
this agent.
>> So it would be kind of like the thinking
message in GPT or Claude kind of resteer
the rest the thing. It's like, oh, it
seems like I'm off track. I should be
focusing on helping you with X instead
of Y.
>> Exactly. Exactly that. And that's it's
the exact same architecture. Nothing is
different except instead of printing to
terminal, you're now printing to
console. Oh, printing to console, you're
now saying invoice. That's it. Only the
stood out is slightly different.
>> Um, I think this this is a really really
important concept. So like perhaps we
could later talk about like how to go
change this from a voice agent.
>> Actually, this would be a really dope
episode is just like how to use a small
model and use a supervisor to inject
messages into the context. I would love
to build that out. That sounds that
that's really that's something I've been
like thinking about for a while.
>> If if we can polish up this code dexture
then it's literally going to be the
exact same code as before because what
you'll notice here is what we're doing
here is at a very very fast rate we're
calling write report which is already
the method that we are calling to write
the actual report when we're calling the
run method. Um when we're calling the
run method right over here we're still
calling write report. Yeah,
>> there's no real difference there except
except the runtime is actually just
doing it with a threading based approach
and the other one is doing it with a
like sequential approach. So we're going
to do the same thing when we go design
these systems.
Sick.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think for any deep
research like the the supervisor pattern
is also really interesting and I
wouldn't be surprised if that's kicking
around the inside of like the OpenAI
deep research tools where while it's
running you have another model reviewing
and like potentially interrupting and
resetting the context.
>> Exactly. It
>> sick.
>> I'll pause here. Uh we'll push out all
this code. Um I'm actually surprised
that it works. We clearly can do a lot
better here because it doesn't actually
reset the state in case I tell it to
reset. So really, if I interrupt it,
what it should be doing is it should be
going back to phase one. If I interrupt
in phase two, if I interrupt in the
middle of phase three, it should go back
to phase two or possibly even phase one.
So I could do a little bit better there.
>> Or I could if it's interrupted, I can
ask a model how it should be
interrupted. But at least for now, I
think this shows the principles behind
what you could go do.
>> Yeah. And I think modeling this as like
a formal state machine architecture,
I've found that especially coding agents
are quite good at working in that world
where the boundaries and the transitions
are like clearly enforced by the by the
like structures and the interfaces that
you build.
>> Yeah, exactly. Questions from anyone
today? If not, we have I have
two interesting things to show.
Okay, it sounds like there's not as many
questions. So, I will I'll pause for
like two seconds and then we'll see if
people want to see something wild.
>> Are you gonna Are you going to make me a
liar about everything I posted in the
BAML chat today or in the Zoom chat
about BAML not doing uh not doing
orchestration?
>> No, but I'll show you something kind of
cool.
Um so this is something that we have
been thinking about really really hard
which is how how does it work if people
want to really understand their code
under the hood. So one of the things
that we've been thinking about is how
can you get visuals directly from code.
So I'll play for a second and I'll show
you what I mean. So here for example
what we are using is we're actually
using markdown syntax in code to signify
sections of code that are meaningful
under the hood.
And when you go see this what ends up
happening is you can now take your
markdown syntax in your code and
automatically render it as actually
lines of code. What that really means is
you can actually jump from markdown to
code with clickth through definitions.
So you can see exactly what parts of
your code are doing what. And then more
complicated graphs can also be
visualized right away without you having
>> This is so dope. This is really And
because you own the parser and you're
tokenizing the the a you can you can map
those things together and imbue the
meaning directly.
>> Exactly. Um Exactly.
>> That's sick. So the idea is that instead
of having to go build the markdown
separately and instead of having to go
uh go do everything. Is it live already?
It should not be live. Um
this should not be live. I'd be so
scared. It's not live. Thank god. um
instead of having to go and do what we
did over here, which is like we built
the diagrams out over here, then we
built the mermaid, then we're going to
go write code, and now we become
detached from the actual diagram in our
code. Our theory is it should be really
nice if you could actually attach
everything together and just go write
the code sequentially and not have to
think hard about it. Uh and this will
help with both like if cloud code is
generating a bunch of code now I'll be
able to go and actually review the
diagram directly that cloud code
generated instead of having to think
about it. The idea is you get all the
benefits of graph code without having to
write graph code.
>> That's when will it be live
rocks.
>> I mean it does work as you saw. U
hopefully soon. We'll do we'll we'll
talk about it soon but hopefully soon.
Uh we're I think we're touring complete
now. So we'll have a couple more updates
coming in soon.
>> No building programming languages as a
bit and then suddenly turned it into uh
that was one of the coolest demos I've
seen in a long time. I can't
>> soon as in more like when Halfife 3
comes out.
>> So never.
>> Um well soon.
>> Okay. Um, you can generate Minecraft
block maps with code. Um, but yeah, I
just thought that given that we were
talking about sequence diagrams and how
we think about it, I thought it was
relevant to show people at least how we
think about approaching all these
things.
>> Did you know the math works out? I have
I have been waiting half of my life by
by years for Halfife 3 to come out. So,
I hope it's sooner than that.
>> Well, I guess the next half your life is
a lot longer. So, yeah, I hope so, too.
Um, this was super dope, man. I I I I
learned some things. Um, I think this is
great. So, for everyone else, we'll
we'll get the code pushed up and the
show notes pushed out and you'll get an
email with uh everything we talked
about. Um, do we know what we're talking
about next week?
>> We do. We're doing how to use cloud code
for non non-coding tasks. I thought that
was going to be a really really fun
episode.
>> Oh, yeah. Um, yeah, that's going to be a
blast. There's a lot of people talking
about how to um how they're using cloud
code to manage non-technical things just
by having it, you know, work over a
giant knowledge graph of markdown files
and build small scripts and integrate
them in. So, uh something I've been
hacking on for a while and gotten really
interested in. So, uh we'll give a deep
dive on how we do that.
>> All right, with that the code is going
live and then you all will have it and
then we'll send out the stuff soon.
>> Super dope. Thanks everybody. Thanks.
Byebye. Bye
>> everyone.